there's a book called the bell curve
written in 1994 written by psychologist
Richard hernstein and political
scientist Charles Murray
why was this book so controversial
this is a fascinating book I know
Charles Murray I've had many
conversations with with him yeah what is
the book about the book is about the
importance of intelligence
in everyday life
that's what the book is about it's an
empirical book it has a statistical
analyzes a very large databases that
show that essentially IQ scores or their
equivalent are correlated to all kinds
of social uh problems uh and social
benefits
and
that in itself is not where the
controversy about that book came
the controversy was about one chapter in
that book and that is a chapter about
the average difference in mean scores
between black Americans and white
Americans
and these are the terms that were used
in the book at the time and are still
used to some extent
um
and
historically
or really for for decades
it has been observed
that
disadvantaged groups score on average
lower
than caucasians
on
on academic tests tests of mental
ability and especially on IQ tests and
the difference is about a standard
deviation which is about 15 points which
is a substantial difference
um
in the book
hernstein and Murray in this one chapter
assert clearly and unambiguously
that whether this average difference is
due to genetics or not they are agnostic
they don't know moreover they assert
they don't care
because you wouldn't treat anybody
differently knowing that if there was a
genetic component or not because that's
a group average finding every individual
has to be treated as an individual you
can't make any assumption about what
that person's intellectual ability might
be from the fact of a average group
different they're very clear about this
nonetheless
people took away I'm going to choose my
words carefully because I have a feeling
that many critics didn't actually read
these read the book
they took away that hernstein and Murray
were saying that blacks are genetically
inferior
that was the take home message and if
they weren't saying it they were
implying it because they had a chapter
that discussed this empirical
observation of a difference
and isn't this horrible
and so the reaction to that book
was
incendiary
what do we know about from that book and
the research Beyond
uh about race differences
and intelligence it's still the most
incendiary Topic in Psychology nothing
has changed that anybody who even
discusses it is easily
uh called a racist just for discussing
it it's become fashionable to find
racism in any discussion
like this
it's unfortunate
um
the short answer to your question is
there's been very little actual research
on this topic
since 19 since the book of since the
Bell could have even before this really
became incendiary in 1969 with an
article published by an educational
psychologist named Arthur Jensen let's
just take a minute and go back to that
to see the bell curve in a little bit
more historical perspective Arthur
Jensen was a educational psychologist at
UC Berkeley I knew him as well
and
um in 1969 or 68 the Harvard educational
review asked him to take an to do a
review article on the
um early childhood education programs
that were designed to raise the IQs of
minority students
this was before the federally funded
Head Start program Head Start had not
really gotten underway at the time
Jensen undertook his review of what were
a number of demonstration programs
and these demonstration programs were
for young children around kindergarten
age and they were specially designed to
be cognitively stimulating to provide
lunches do all the the things that
people thought would minimize this this
average gap of intelligence tests there
was a a strong belief among virtually
all psychologists that the cause of the
Gap was unequal opportunity due to
racism due to all you know all negative
things in the society and if you could
compensate for this the Gap would go
away so early childhood education back
then was called literally compensatory
education
Jensen looked at these programs he was
an empirical guy he understood
psychometrics
and he wrote a it was over a hundred
page article detailing
these programs and the flaws in their
research design
some of the programs reported IQ gains
of on average five points but a few
reported 10 20 and even 30 point games
one was called the miracle in Milwaukee
the that investigator went to jail
ultimately for fabricating data but the
point is that Jensen wrote an article
that said look the opening sentence of
his Oracle is classic the opening
sentence is I may not quote it exactly
right but it's we have tried
compensatory education and it has failed
and he showed that these games
were essentially nothing you couldn't
really document empirically any gains at
all from these really Earnest efforts
to increase IQ but he went a step
further a fateful step further he said
not only
have these efforts failed but because
they have had essentially no impact we
have to re-examine our assumption that
these differences are caused by
environmental things that we can address
with education we need to consider
a genetic influence whether there's a
genetic influence on this group
difference so you said that this is one
of the more controversial works I think
inFamous Paper in all of psychology I
would go on to say
because in 1969
the genetic data was very skimpy on this
question skimpy and controversy it's
always been controversial but it was
even skimpy and controversial
it's kind of a long story that I go into
a little bit in more detail in in the
book of Neuroscience of intelligence uh
but to say he was vilified is an
understatement I mean he couldn't talk
it at the American Psychological
Association uh without bomb threats
clearing the the lecture hall campus
security watched him all the time they
opened his mail uh he had to retreat to
a a different address
uh this was uh one of the earliest kinds
this was before the internet and and
kind of Internet social media mobs uh
but it was that intense
and I have written that overnight after
the publication of this article
all intelligence research became
Radioactive
nobody wanted to talk about it
uh and then it it didn't it it nobody
was doing more research and then the
bell curve came along
and the Johnson controversy was dying
down I have stories that Jensen told me
about his interaction with the Nixon
White House on this issue I mean it was
this was like a really big deal
it was some unbelievable stories but you
know he told me this so I kind of
believe these stories nonetheless 25
years later 25 years later all the
silence basically saying that you know
this
uh nobody wants to do this kind of
research there's so much pressure so
much attack against this kind of
research and here's uh
sort of a bold stupid crazy people that
decide to dive right back in and I
wonder how much discussion that was do
we include this chapter or not Murray
has said they discussed it and they felt
they should include it
and they were very careful in the way
they they wrote it which did them no
good
uh so
um as a matter of fact when the bell
curve came out it was so controversial I
got a call from a television show called
Nightline it was with a broadcaster
called Ted Koppel who had this evening
show I think it was on late at night
talked about news it was a straight up
news thing yeah and uh producer called
and asked if if I would be on it to talk
about the uh the bell curve
and I said you know it it she asked me
what I thought about the bell curve as a
book and I said look it's a very good
book it talks about the role of
intelligence in society
and she said no no what do you think
about the chapter on Race that's what we
want you to talk about
I remember this conversation
I said well
she said what would you say if you were
on TV
and I said well what I would say is that
it's not at all clear if there's any
genetic component
to intelligence
um any differences but if there were a
strong genetic component that would be a
good thing
and you know complete silence on the
other end of the phone yeah and she said
well what do you mean
and I said well if it's the more genetic
any difference is the more it's
biological
and if it's biological we can figure out
how to fix it I see that's interesting
she said would you say that on
television yes I said no and so that was
the end of that so that's for more like
uh
biology
is
um
within the reach of science
and the environment is a public policy
is social and all those kinds of things
it's it from your perspective whichever
one you think is more amenable to
Solutions in the in the short term is
the one that excites you but uh you
saying that it's good
uh uh the the truth of genetic
differences no matter what the between
groups
is is a painful
harmful potentially potentially
dangerous thing this is let me ask you
to this question whether it's bell curve
or any research on Race differences
can that be used to increase the amount
of racism in the world can that be used
to increase the amount of hate in the
world do you think about this kind of
stuff I've thought about this a lot not
as a scientist but as a person
um and my senses there is such enormous
reservoirs of hate and racism
that have nothing to do with scientific
knowledge of the data
that speak against that
that no I I don't I don't want to give
racist groups of veto power over what
scientists study
if you think that the differences and by
the way virtually no one disagrees that
there are differences in scores it's all
about what causes them and how to fix it
so if you think this is a cultural
problem then you must ask the problem
what do you want it do you want to
change anything about the culture or are
you okay with the culture because you
don't feel it's appropriate to change a
person's culture so are you okay with
that and the fact that that may lead to
disadvantages in school achievement it's
a question
are if you think it's environmental what
are the environmental parameters that
can be fixed I'll tell you one lead in
you know lead from gasoline in the
atmosphere lead in paint lead in in
water that's an environmental toxin that
Society has the means to eliminate and
they should yeah just to sort of trying
to find some um
insights and conclusion to this very
difficult topic
uh is there been research on environment
versus genetics nature versus nurture on
this question of race differences
there is not no one wants to do this
research it's first of all it's hard
research to do second of all it's it's a
Minefield no one wants to spend their
career on it tenured people don't want
to do it let alone students
um the way I talk about it well before I
tell you the way I I talk about I want
to say one more thing about Jensen
he was once asked by a journalist
straight out are you a racist
his answer was very interesting his
answer was I've thought about that a lot
and I've concluded it doesn't matter
this now I know what he meant by this
the guts to say that wow he was a very
unusual person I think he had a touch of
Asperger's Syndrome to tell you the
truth because I I saw him in many
circumstances it would be canceled on
Twitter immediately with that sentence
yeah but what he what he meant was he
had a hypothesis
yeah and with respect to group
differences he called it the default
hypothesis he said whatever factors
affect individual intelligence are
likely the same factors that affect
group differences it was the default but
it was a hypothesis
it should be tested and if it turned out
empirical tests didn't support the
hypothesis he was happy to move on to
something else
he was absolutely committed to that
scientific ideal
that that it's an empirical question
we should look at it and let's see what
happens the scientific method cannot be
racist from his perspective it doesn't
matter what the scientists
if they if they follow the scientific
method
it doesn't matter what they believe and
if they are biased and they consciously
or unconsciously
bias the data
other people will come along to
replicate it they will fail and the
process over time will work so let me
push back on this idea
because psychology to me is full of gray
areas
and what I've observed about psychology
even replication crisis aside
is that something about the media
something about journalism something
about the the virality of ideas in the
public sphere
they misinterpret they take up things
from studies
uh willfully or from ignorance
misinterpret findings and tell
narratives around that
I personally believe for me I'm not
saying that broadly about science but
for me
it's my responsibility to anticipate the
ways in which findings will be
misinterpreted
so I've had I thought about this a lot
because I published papers on uh
semi-autonomous vehicles and those you
know cars people die in cars
there's people that written me letters
saying emails nobody writes letters I
wish they did uh that have blood in my
hands because of things I I would say
positive or negative there's
consequences in the same way when your
researcher of intelligence I'm sure you
might get emails or at least people
might believe that finding your study is
going to be used by a large number of
people to increase the amount of hate in
the world
I think there's some responsibility on
scientists but for me I think there's a
great responsibility uh to anticipate
the ways things will be misinterpreted
and there you have to
first of all decide whether you want to
say a thing at all
or do the study at all publish the study
at all and two the words with which you
explain it see it's uh I find this on
Twitter a lot actually which is when I
when I write a tweet I'm usually just
doing so innocently
I I'll I'll I'll write it you know it
takes me like five seconds to write it
or whatever 30 seconds to write it and
then I'll think all right I like close
my eyes open and try to see how will the
world interpret this like what are the
ways in which this will be
misinterpreted and I'll sometimes adjust
that tweet to see like
yeah so in my mind it's clear but that's
because it's my mind from which this
tweet came but you have to think in a
fresh mind that sees this
uh and it's spread across
a large number of other Minds how will
the interpretation morph I mean for a
tweet it's a silly thing it doesn't
matter but for a scientific
um paper and study and finding
I think it matters so I don't know I
don't know what your thoughts about on
that because maybe for Jensen uh the
data is there
what do you want me to do this is a
scientific process that's been carried
out if you think the data was polluted
by bias do other studies that reveal the
bias uh but the data is there and we
like I have would I'm not a poet
I'm not a uh literary right like what do
you want me to do I'm just presenting
you the data what do you think on that
Spectrum what's the role of a scientist
the reason I do podcasts yeah the reason
I write books for the public
is to explain what I think the data mean
and what I think the data don't mean
I don't do very much on Twitter other
than to retweet references to papers yes
I don't think it's my role to explain
these because they're complicated
they're nuanced
but when you decide not to do a
scientific study because you're or not
to publish a result because you're
afraid the result
could be could be harmful or insensitive
that's not an unreasonable thought
and people will make different
conclusions and decisions about that
I wrote about this I wrote uh I I'm the
editor of a journal called intelligence
which published which publishes
scientific papers sometimes we publish
papers on group differences
those papers sometimes are controversial
these papers are written for a
scientific audience they're not written
for the Twitter audience so I don't
promote them very much on on Twitter
um but in a scientific paper
you have to now choose your words
carefully also because those papers are
picked up by non-scientists by writers
of various kinds and you have to be
available to discuss what you're saying
and what you're not saying
sometimes
you are successful at having a good
conversation like we are today that's
that doesn't start out pejorative
other times I've been asked to
participate in debates where my role
would be to justify race science
well you can see you start out
you know and that was a BBC request that
I had that I received I have so much
it's a love-hate relationship mostly
hate with these shallow Journal uh
journalism organizations so they would
want to use you
as a kind of in a debate setting to
communicate as to like there is raise
differences between groups and make that
into debate yes and put you in a role of
um justifying racism to justify that's
what they're asking me courses like
educating about this this field of the
science of intelligence yeah I want to
say one more thing before we get off the
the normal distribution you also asked
me what is the science after the bell
curve and the short answer is there's
not much new work but whatever work
there is supports the idea that there
still are group differences
it's arguable whether those differences
have diminished at all or not
and there is still a major problem in
underperformance in for school
achievement
for many uh disadvantaged and minority
students and there so far is no way to
fix it uh what do we do with this
information what uh is this is this now
a task now we'll talk about the future
uh on the neuroscience and the biology
side but in terms of this information as
a society in the public policy in the
political space in the social space What
do we do with this information I've
thought a lot about this the first step
is to have people interested in policy
understand what the data actually show
to pay attention to intelligence data
you can read policy papers about
education and using your word processor
you can search for the word intelligence
you can search a a 20 000 Word document
in a second and find out the word
intelligence does not appear anywhere
in most discussions about what to do
about achievement gaps I'm not talking
about test gaps I'm talking about actual
achievement gaps in schools which
everyone agrees is a problem
the word intelligence doesn't appear
among educators
that's fascinating as a matter of fact
in California
there has been tremendous controversy
about recent attempts to revise the
curriculum for math in high schools
and we had a Stanford professor of
Education who was running this review
assert there's no such thing as Talent
of mathematical Talent
and she wanted to get rid of the
advanced classes in math because you
know not everyone could do that
now of course this has been very
controversial they've retreated somewhat
but the idea that a university Professor
was in charge of this who believes
not that there's no
Talent
that it doesn't exist
this is rather shocking let alone the
complete absence of intelligence data by
the way let me tell you something about
what the intelligence data show let's
take race out of it
uh even though the origins of these
studies uh were were a long time ago
I'm blocking on the name of the report
the Coleman report was a famous report
about education and they measured all
kinds of variables about schools about
teachers and they looked at academic
achievement as an outcome
and they found the most predictive
variables of Education outcome were the
variables the student brought with him
or her into the school essentially their
ability
and that when you combine the school and
the teacher variables together
quality of the school the funding of the
school the quality of the teachers their
education you put all the teacher and
school variables together it barely
accounted for 10 of the variance
and this has been replicated now
you know so the best research we have
shows that school variables and teacher
variables together account for about 10
percent of student academic achievement
now you want to have some policy on
improving academic achievement how much
money do you want to put into teacher
education how much money you want to put
into the quality of of the school
administration you know who you can ask
you can ask the Gates Foundation
because they spent a tremendous amount
of money doing that and they us at the
end of it because they're measurement
people they want to you know they want
to know the data they found it had no
impact at all and they've kind of pulled
out of of that kind of program
so oh boy
let me ask let me ask you this is me
talking but there's
just the two of us or just the two of us
but I'm gonna say uh some funny and
ridiculous things so it's you're surely
you're not approving of it uh but
there's a movie called Clerks
I mean you probably I've seen it I've
seen it yeah there's a funny scene in
there where a lovely couple are talking
about the number of previous sexual
partners they had
and
um uh the the woman says that I believe
she just had a handful like two or three
or something like that sexual partners
but then she also mentioned
um that she
um what's that called uh fellatio what's
the scientific but she went you know I
gave a [ __ ] to uh 37 guys I believe
it is and uh so that has to do with the
truth
so sometimes knowing the truth
can get in the way of a successful
relationship of Love of some of the
human flourishing
and that's seems to me that's at the
core here that facing some kind of
truth that's not able to be changed
it makes it difficult to sort of
is limiting as opposed to empowering
that's the concern if you sort of test
for intelligence and lay the data out
it feels like you will give up on
certain people
you will
you'll you'll sort of start binning
people's like well this is this person
is like let's focus on the average
people well let's focus on the very
intelligent people that's the concern
and and there's a kind of
intuition that if we just don't measure
and we don't use that data that we would
treat everybody equal and give everybody
uh equal opportunity
if we have the data in front of us we're
likely to miss uh distribute the amount
of sort of attention we allocate
resources we allocate uh allocate to
people that's that's probably the
concern it's a realistic concern
and but I think it's a misplaced concern
if you want to fix the problem
if you want to fix the problem you have
to know what the problem is now let me
let me tell you this let's go back to
the bell curve for not the bell curve
but the normal distribution yes
16 percent of the population on average
has an IQ under 85.
which means they're very hard if you
have an IQ under 85 it's very hard to
find gainful employment at a salary
that sustains you at least minimally in
Modern Life
okay not impossible but it's very
difficult
sixteen percent of the population of the
United States is about 51 or 52 million
people with IQs under 85.
this is not a small issue
14 million children have IQs under 85.
is this something we want to ignore
does this have any what is the Venn
diagram between you know when you have
people with IQs under 85 and you have
achievement in school or achievement in
life
there's a lot of overlap there this is
why to go back to the IQ pill if there
were a way
to shift
that curve toward the higher end that
would have a big impact if I could maybe
before we talk about the impact on life
and so on
some of the criticisms of the bell curve
so Stephen J Goode wrote that the bell
curve rests on four incorrect
assumptions okay it'd be just
interesting to get your thoughts on the
four assumptions which are intelligence
must be reducible to a single number
intelligence must be capable of rank
ordering people in a linear order
intelligence must be primarily
genetically based and intelligence must
be essentially immutable maybe not as
criticisms but as
thoughts about intelligence yeah that we
could we could spend a lot of time on
him
yeah he wrote that in what about 1985
1984. he his views were overtly
political not scientific he was a
scientist but his views on this were
overtly political and I would encourage
people listening to this if they really
want to understand
his criticisms they should uh just uh
Google
um what he had to say and Google the
scientific reviews of his book The
mismeasure of man and they will take
these statements apart they were wrong
not only were they wrong but when he
asserted in his first book that you know
that there was no biological basis
essentially to IQ by the time the second
edition came around there were studies
of MRI MRIs of the showing that brain
size eyes brain volume were correlated
to IQ scores which he declined to put in
his book
so I'm learning a lot today I didn't
know
I didn't know the actually the extent of
his work I was just using a few little
Snippets of criticism that's interesting
so there's a battle here he wrote a book
mismeasure of man that's not that's
missing a lot of these scientific uh his
ground book is highly popular in
colleges today you can find it in any
College Bookstore under assigned reading
it's highly popular mismeasure of man
yes highly influential can you speak to
the mismeasurements I'm I'm
undereducated about this so what is this
the book basically criticizing the ideas
in the ball card yeah yeah where those
four things came from and it is really
um a book that was uh really taken apart
Point by Point by a number of people who
I actually understood the data and he
didn't care yeah he didn't care he
didn't it's a politically listen uh
because this is such a sensitive topic
like I said I believe
uh
the the impact of the work as it is
misinterpreted has to be considered
because it's not just going to be
scientific discourse it's going to be
political discourse there's going to be
debates there's going to be
um
uh politically motivated people that
would use messages in each Direction
make it the make something like the bell
curve the enemy or the support for your
uh for for one's racist beliefs and so
um I think you have to consider that but
it's difficult because
you know Nietzsche was used by Hitler to
uh justify a lot of his beliefs and it's
not in it's not exactly on Nietzsche to
to anticipate Hitler so uh or how his
ideas will be misinterpreted and used
for evil but there is a balance there so
I understand this is really interesting
I didn't I didn't know is there any
criticism of the book you find
compelling or interesting or challenging
to you from a scientific perspective
there were factual criticisms uh uh
about the nature of the statistics that
were used the statistical analyzes these
are more technical criticisms and they
were addressed by Murray in a couple of
Articles where he took all the
criticisms and and spoke to them and
people listening to this podcast uh can
certainly find all those online uh and
it's very interesting but Murray went on
to write some additional books two in
the last couple of years uh one about
human diversity where he goes through
the data
refuting the idea that race is only a
social construct with no biological
meaning he he discusses the data it's a
very good discussion you don't have to
agree with it but he presents data in a
cogent way and he talks about the
critics of that and he talks about their
data in a cogent nod personal way it's
it's a it's a very informative
discussion a book is called human
diversity he talks about race and he
talks about gender same thing about sex
differences
and more recently he's written what
might be his final say on this a book
called facing reality
where he talks about this again uh so uh
you know he's he he can certainly defend
himself he doesn't need me to to do that
but I would urge people who have heard
about him and the bell curve and who
think they know what's in it
you are likely Incorrect and you need to
read it for yourself
but it is uh so scientifically it's a
it's a serious subject it's a difficult
subject ethically it's a difficult
subject
everything you said here calmly and
thoughtfully is difficult it's difficult
for me to even consider that g Factor
exists
um I don't mean from like that somehow G
factors inherently racist or sexist or
whatever it's just
it's it's difficult in the way that
considering the fact that we die one day
is difficult that we are limited by our
biology it's difficult and it's
um
is at least from an American perspective
you you like to believe that everything
is possible in this world
that leads us to
what I think
we should do with this information
and what I think we should do with this
information is
unusual
because I think what we need to do is
fund more Neuroscience research on the
molecular biology of learning and memory
because one definition of intelligence
is based on how much you can learn and
how much you can remember yes and if you
accept that definition of intelligence
then there are molecular studies going
on now
and Nobel prizes being won on molecular
biology or molecular neurobiology of
learning and memory
now the step those researchers those
scientists need to take when it comes to
intelligence
is to focus on the concept of individual
differences
intelligence
research has individual differences as
its heart because it it is it assumes
that people differ on this variable and
those differences are meaningful and
need understanding
cognitive psychologists
who have morphed into molecular
biologists studying learning and memory
hate the concept of individual
differences historically
some now are coming around to it
I once sat next to um a Nobel Prize
winner for his work on on memory and I
asked him about individual differences
and he said don't go there it'll set us
back 50 years
but I said I said don't you think
they're the key though to understand why
can some people remember more than
others he said you you don't want to go
there I think the 21st century would be
remembered by the technology and the
science that
goes to individual differences because
we have we have now data we have now the
tools the much much better to start to
measure start to estimate uh not just on
the sort of through tests and like IQ
test type of things sort of uh uh
outside the body kind of things but
measuring all kinds of stuff about the
body so yeah truly go into the molecular
biology to the neurobiology to the
neuroscience